Battered by critics upon the release of its
first season in 2017, Marvel's Iron Fist needed
some serious image rehabilitation going into
its sophomore outing.
But the show's reception and quality actually
has started to turn around - and it's even
set a Rotten Tomatoes record in the process.
According to a breakdown of data by the review
aggregating site, Iron Fist has set a record
for the biggest jump in quality between the
first and second seasons of a TV series that
Rotten Tomatoes has ever measured.
But just because Iron Fist has clearly improved
doesn't mean the show is suddenly great now.
According to the second season's breakdown
on the website, only 50% of critics across
30 reviews deemed the series as being worth
another look.
On an A-to-F scale, that's still a failing
grade - though it's definitely a big improvement
over the first season's 19% score.
When Iron Fist's first season was released
in 2017, critics derided the show as being
one of the single worst properties Marvel
Television had yet produced.
It was a feat which to this date has been
exceeded only by ABC's Inhumans series, which
was released the same year to a 12% Rotten
Tomatoes score.
Despite the major second season bump from
critics, it's hard to characterize Iron Fist
as being a must-see-series yet.
The finding is mostly encouraging for viewers
who are already fans of the show, with the
second season having a little more of what
people like, and a little less of what they
don't.
Unlike Hannibal or Breaking Bad, series which
started good and then got even better, Iron
Fist started off terribly, and is now more-or-less
"okay".
Even the more negative reviews for the series
are now characterizing the show as being "fine",
"mildly entertaining", or "merely boring."
In other words, Iron Fist is still not exactly
appointment viewing - but it probably won't
ruin your day to see an episode anymore.
Partially explaining the turnaround in quality
is the fact that Iron Fist's second season
was written under the guidance of a new showrunner:
Raven Metzner.
As a screenwriter and producer, Metzner previously
worked on the TV series Sleepy Hollow, as
well as the shows Heroes Reborn, Falling Skies,
and Daybreak.
He also wrote the screenplay for the movie
Elektra - but that was a long time ago, so
we'll try and ignore that.
Metzner came on board Iron Fist as a replacement
for season one's showrunner, Scott Buck, who'd
earned himself a questionable reputation as
a showrunner after overseeing the Showtime
serial killer series Dexter as it fell from
prestige drama into self-parody.
He was also the showrunner for Marvel's Inhumans,
which was quietly cancelled after eight profoundly
bad episodes.
Alongside the behind-the-scenes personnel
shifts, Iron Fist's second season also saw
marked improvements to its cinematography
and fight choreography, which are generally
regarded as being pretty important ingredients
for a martial arts superhero show.
The new season also included an increased
focus on the characters Misty Knight and Colleen
Wing, better known in Marvel Comics as the
Daughters of the Dragon.
Season two sees the fighters spend some time
teaming up, taking on the bad guys to enjoyable
effect.
Misty also gets a spiffy new robotic arm,
while Colleen earns herself some impressive
new powers.
In short, while Iron Fist is still the lowest-rated
series in the Marvel-Netflix collection, it's
significantly closed the gap in quality between
itself and the other five shows.
Unfortunately, Iron Fist's second season still
seems to struggle with the same issues that
affect all of the shows in Marvel's Netflix
universe.
Whether it's Daredevil, Jessica Jones, Luke
Cage or The Punisher, every one of Marvel's
streaming series has been critiqued to some
extent - and Iron Fist is no exception.
It still suffers from problematic pacing,
some aimless subplots, and occasionally subpar
production values, but the season as a whole
is a big step in the right direction.
Now that Iron Fist is watchable, maybe it's
time to tweak and retool all the series, and
finally unlock the full potential of this
corner of the Marvel Universe.